Hello world it Saroj and I'm going to
give you five steps to study machine
learning as effectively
as possible in this video.
If you're new to this channel,
hit the subscribe button to
keep up with my AI content.
The first step to studying machine
learning effectively is to live a healthy
lifestyle.
That means taking care of yourself as a
biological learning machine consisting
of both mind and body.
It's important to eliminate
what Dr. Daniel Amen the
author of use your brain to
change your age called a and t's
or automatic negative thoughts.
These are thoughts that everybody has
had at some point like I'm not smart
enough or I'm too old or
my GPU is AMD quality.
Your brain is a super computer
and your self talk is the program.
It will run so program your computer.
Well,
in this information age,
you have access to every machine learning
resource you need including data,
algorithms, computing,
power and education.
There's no excuse to say,
I can learn machine learning because of x.
Having a positive peer
group can help with this.
Find people that encourage and
support your learning journey.
You are the sum of the five people you
spend the most time with and if you can't
find a supportive group locally,
find your nearest school of AI chapter
or hang out in our slack channel.
It can be just as fulfilling having social
interactions online as it is offline.
Also,
exercise is super important to learning.
Research shows that anything that's good
for your heart is also good for your
brain.
People who exercise regularly have better
blood flow and oxygen in their brains
and as an inevitable result,
perform better on mental acuity tests.
Find a physical activity you actually
enjoy like swimming or biking and that way
you'll stick to it despite the
pain and the phrase you are,
what you eat is very much true.
Try to avoid too much processed food
and sugar and drink lots of water.
Make this a part of your lifestyle.
I myself eat a mostly Paleo Diet and do
full body workouts using weights three
times a week.
Also getting a good night's rest is
essential because it's when your brain
consolidates short to long term memory.
Lastly,
information overload is a real thing in
today's notification driven society and
can lead to burning out.
Make sure to take time to disconnect.
Give yourself a break.
It's okay to isolate yourself from
the Internet to rejuvenate a bit.
I put my phone on mode at least two hours
before I sleep every night and try to
have at least one 24 hour period a week
where I'm completely disconnected in
nature. This second step is to
optimize your learning environment.
What is your study space look like?
I find I can study more efficiently when
I do so in a designated study space.
I'm not as productive if I'm learning
in the same room where I sleep,
so I go to an office.
It's my designated learning only zone
and it's easier to focus when you're in a
clean environment.
So don't have a cluttered desk.
Try to minimize distractions
like Black Mirror as well.
Everybody has different preferences
on what is considered a distraction.
I try and eliminate all sound
using noise canceling headphones.
Libraries are always a great place to
study since they are quiet and coffee
shops work as well.
The third step is to create a
personalized learning path for yourself.
I've now made several learning paths that
hundreds of thousands of wizards have
participated in,
whether they're related to deep learning
or machine learning or general computer
science.
The way I designed these curriculums was
by first thinking of the topics in AI
that interested me the most.
Then finding relevant resources using
Google helped me learn about those topics
in order of complexity,
I follow my curiosity.
That's the best way to
stick to any learning path.
As long as it's curiosity driven,
it's something that you're
actually interested in.
You'll have no problem putting
in the time to learn it.
Curiosity killed the cat,
right? Wait, scratch that.
Think of it like a metta curriculum.
Your curriculum can consist of
other full curriculums, blog posts,
research papers, podcasts, books.
It can be as diverse as possible.
Some people can learn best from videos
while others learn best from pure text.
By having a diverse set
of learning resources,
you'll learn what works best for
you and in your learning journey.
It's okay to update your
curriculum as you go.
Sometimes you might find something new
you'd like to focus on more deeply and
you can allow yourself to do that.
As long as you have a set of
small achievable learning goals,
you'll have the reward feedback to
complete your entire curriculum.
A great easy way to do this is to
participate in the 100 days of ml code
challenge.
It's a pledge to dedicate at least
one hour every day to studying machine
learning. Linked to details will
be in the video description.
The fourth step is to prioritize.
This is a skill that you'll
always be improving at.
There's a bunch of things you
could be doing at any given moment,
but it's important to focus
on the most important tasks.
Multitasking is a myth.
Switching between tasks is what's actually
happening and this takes more time
and it's less productive.
Also,
it causes more errors every
time you switch tasks you've
got to regain focus and
flow,
which takes between five and 20 minutes.
I create a to do list of
tasks for each day, week,
month and year and try to
stick to it as best as I can.
It's worked pretty well so far.
Evaluate each item on your list as to its
importance for your learning goals and
eliminate the unnecessary. You can use
this framework of a two by two grid,
with four quadrants to help you
prioritize mapping out concepts.
It balances how useful a concept is
with how much time you have to learn it.
And the last step is to
be an active learner.
We can use the fast framework
to do this effectively.
It's an acronym that stands for forget,
activate state,
teach and we'll help you
learn anything faster.
Forget means that when you're
learning something new,
try and temporarily forget three things.
First,
forget what you already
know about the subject.
Lots of people don't learn faster because
they feel like they already know the
information,
but our minds are like parachutes.
They only work when opened. Mike
drop. It's like that Yoda saying,
you must unlearn what you have learned.
Also,
forget about anything that's not urgent.
Remember the brain can't multitask
and if you aren't fully present,
you won't learn as well and
forget your limitations,
those beliefs that your memory is bad
or you don't have the right education to
learn.
The a stands for active.
Most of us were taught in school that
learning means being lectured to.
The opposite is actually true.
We learn by creating information
and being active in the process.
It's not a spectator sport.
That means asking questions
on stack overflow,
taking notes while you consume educational
content and coding up solutions
yourself. Spend most of your
time doing not consuming.
The s stands for states.
All learning is state dependent.
If you feel bored,
you won't be able to learn as well.
So choose states of curiosity,
happiness and eagerness.
You can do this by altering your posture
or ideating about how learning AI will
help you in the long run.
By giving you limitless career
options and the t stands for teach,
you can literally cut your learning
curve in half if you will learn with the
intention of teaching it to somebody else.
This is what I do full time.
I learned to teach and that's
why I can learn so much. So fast.
I'm always teaching and while learning,
start with the simplest
explanations first.
That way you don't give up.
For example,
if you're trying to learn about
variational auto encoders,
start with a video or blog posts
that explains it at a high level,
not the paper. And as you familiarize
yourself with the concept,
you can progressively increase the
complexity of the educational content you
consume. Oh, and one more
thing. While you learn,
make sure to take frequent breaks,
your attention and retention
diminish after about 30 minutes.
So breaks can help reset that.
And that's pretty much it.
I'll have links to everything I've
talked about and a bunch of learning
resources for you in the video
description. It's learning time.
Are you excited?
If you like this video,
hit subscribe and I'll marry you and make
sure to connect with me on Instagram,
Twitter, and Facebook for more educational
content. For now, I've got to learn.
So thanks for watching.